nous savions tout de suite que Morgan était très
spéciale
en un mois, marchant et parlant
dans les six ans, elle a dépassé
nos attentes les plus folles, elle est comme une
enfant
Morgan est une enfant, elle a fait une crise de colère
Le comportement de Morgan était très malheureux,
elle apprend et elle a le droit de
faire des erreurs
elle n'est pas elle et elle n'a pas le droit oh
tu as tort à ce sujet
non elle s'il te plaît ne le fais pas malgré les
revers actuels oui les résultats de notre
investissement sont assez
remarquables arrêtez
bonjour Morgan ravi de vous rencontrer
en chair
et en os vous  Je vais voir maintenant à quel point nous pouvons être heureux
bébé n'y allez pas
oh mon dieu
nous sommes tous très heureux d'être heureux tôt
j'imagine que ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai
docteur c'est Lee weathers de l'entreprise je
cherche juste des informations sur
Morgan Morgan était un troisième dans la tentation
notre petite percée c'est la prochaine
étape de l'évolution
il est bio-conçu avec de l'ADN synthétique
en un mois en marchant et en parlant en
six mois Dixie's est nos
attentes les plus folles que j'aimerais d  Discutez de l'
incident si ça va
elle a fait une crise il y avait de la joie dans son
cœur avant qu'on la remette dans cette
boîte tu te sens un peu triste Morgan
oui tu aimes ça ici oui eh bien tu
aimes ça
J'aime mes amis tu  pense qu'ils
te traitent comme un ami Je veux dire que tu penses
qu'il est normal que des amis
s'enferment dans des cages que feriez-vous si je
recommandais que vous ne soyez pas
autorisé à quitter cette pièce oh si je
recommandais que vous soyez licencié nous
devrions mettre fin à cela  naturellement ce que tu
fais où Morgan initie le verrouillage
ce que tu ne comprends pas ce Morgan
évolue toujours les gens de cette maison
sont en danger il faut y mettre fin
sept six n'aie pas peur cinq quatre
je commence à me sentir moi-même